à quelques minutes du départ du verre
trade versailles samedi soir les
participants pour la plupart novices
dans la course de nuit hésite entre
impatience et prudents avant d'avaler 17
km à la lampe frontale se vidant qui
c'est tous les jours qu'on concours mais
ça va pas fois que je courais la nuit et
ça a l'air plutôt plutôt attrayant alors
faire attention aux racines au petit
trot et c'est aragon à la frontale donc
comment ça se passe on est tous pareils
va on va se battre en voir ce que ça
donne la particularité du ver treille
les son départ pendant une vingtaine de
minutes
les coureurs ont profité des dernières
lueurs du jour avant de se retrouver
dans le noir total
au milieu de la forêt de porchefontaine
à chacun sa tactique lampes allumées dès
le début pour certains d'autres la
conserve pour l'entrée des bois autant
dire qu'il fallait faire attention où
vous mettez les pieds forcément encore
un peu moins vite surtout dans les
descentes les choses comme ça on est un
peu plus vigilant cailloux mais bon ça
devrait aller autre exercice de la
course de nuit
le passage de relais car le ver treille
secours est aussi en équipe et dans le
noir passé le témoin son coéquipier
n'est pas chose aisée cette course
inédite était organisée par 35 élèves du
lycée marie-curie de versailles dans le
cadre de leur enseignement d'exploration
contrat rempli donc pour cette première
édition près de 200 participants ont
tenté l aventure